well pink has been causing some trouble
for rolling stone magazine yeah the
singer blasted the magazine in a series
of instagram posts after the outlet
posted their ranking of the top grammys
performances of all time you guys have
been irrelevant since 1990 she wrote
this is the magazine that used to
feature people like john lennon and
muddy waters
pink went on to criticize the magazine
for writing about reality tv stars
saying when style over substance and
revenue over authenticity went into play
that's when snooki became acceptable
coverage give me a break she added i've
felt that way for decades as so many of
my favorite artists and my peers have
this isn't just about their horrendous
opinion of reading grammy's performances
it's decades of wasting trees and
people's time
she did not hold back now kendrick
lamar's performance of the black or the
berry and all right at the 2016 grammy's
top rolling stones list which also
included performances by beyonce and
taylor swift and although pink has
performed at the grammys more than once
over the years she didn't make the
magazine's top 25s